As you begin to look into healthcare analytics,
you may find yourself searching for definitions
and differences between health informatics,
bioinformatics and healthcare analytics.
It’s not hard to see why, as the three
disciplines work in similar areas of the health,
computing and IT space. But, in fact,
they are very different and have uniquely
defined roles that complement one another.
Health analytics and informatics are both
essential for the success of healthcare
organizations. Healthcare organizations
must be able to manage, analyze,
and interpret data in order to identify
the best ways to deliver high quality care.
Although some consider analytics and
informatics to be interchangeable terms,
the two are distinctively
different in concept and practice.
Health informatics is the interdisciplinary
study of the design, development, adoption, and
application of IT-based innovations in healthcare
services delivery, management, and planning.
In practical terms, healthcare informatics
relates to the ecosystem of data and systems
that support operational and clinical workflows
rather than the analysis of data found therein.
The diagram depicts the relationship between
the 2 major domain of health informatics:
Health Information Technology which focuses on
the tools and machines, and Health Information
Management, focuses on the organization and
dissemination of information. Example of the
job scope of a health informaticist may include
Managing EHR integration into clinical workflows,
Reduce health disparities,
Engage patients and families,
Improve care coordination, Maintain
privacy of health information,
Improve access to health information,
and Improve education and compliance.
Healthcare analytics, on the other hand, refers
to analysis of the data to inform decisions,
improve quality and performance
of the healthcare organization.
Health data analysts have the advanced knowledge
to acquire, manage, analyze, interpret,
and transform data into accurate, consistent, and
timely information. Example of the job scope of a
health data analyst may include Increase access to
care and decrease costs using business analytics,
Overcome re-imbursement
challenges using smart algorithm,
Improve patient outcomes using big data analytics,
Optimize resources using descriptive analytics,
Conduct research using advanced analytics, Improve
clinical quality using operational analytics,
and Detect fraud using prescriptive
and real-time analytics.
Another field of prominent importance in
the field of analytics and informatics is
bioinformatics. Bioinformatics focus on analysis,
interpretation, data mining, and integration
of heterogeneous ‘omics’ data, including the
genome, transcriptome , proteome, metabolome,
and algorithmic modeling of biological
systems. It has two roles. As a technology,
bioinfomatics is a powerful technology to manage,
search, and analyze big data in life sciences.
As a methodology, bioinfomatics is a top-down
holistic, data-driven, genome-wide, and systems
approach that generates new hypotheses, finds new
patterns, and discovers new functional elements.
It complements traditional experimental
biology methods. A seamless combination
of computational and experimental methods should
be the best way to study a biological question.
The Bio in bioinformatics signifies the biological
questions it studies, many of which can be
grouped under the conceptual framework from
genotype to phenotype and the Central Dogma.
Some examples may help you understand
better. For instance, sequence alignment.
Are the sequences of two genes or proteins
similar? Could they be homologous? How can
we find the closest homologue of the gene
we are studying from the vast databases?
Can I use the known function of a known gene
to guide the study of my gene of interest?
Given DNA and genome sequences, how can we find
the genes in the vast genome? How can we compare
the similarity and difference between two whole
genomes and reconstruct the evolutionary history?
What are the syntenic regions between two
genomes? How can we identify which genomic
regions are methylated? At the level of RNA
expression, we often need to find out which genes
are differentially expressed between two organs
or tissues, between tumor and normal tissues,
or between two different developmental stages?
At the level of proteins, how do you identify
the expressed proteins from mass spec data?
Proteins do not exist in a linear form in nature.
Instead, they are folded into beautiful
three dimensional structures in nature.
How can we predict the three-dimensional
structure of a protein from its sequence?
Molecules do not exist or function in isolation.
Instead, they form complex molecular network.
How can we construct protein-protein interaction
networks, transcription regulation networks,
and metabolic and signaling pathways? What
are the dynamic features of these networks?
Furthermore, with these data and researches,
how can we simulate a virtual cell?
Last but not least, how do you compare different
people’s genomes and use population genetic
approaches to compare the genomes of the ill
and the healthy, and identify the gene mutations
that cause diseases? From these examples,
we can see that there are many interesting
and important questions in life sciences
that await our bioinformatics investigation.
Seeing bioinformatics from another angle,
the informatics in Bioinformatics signifies
the information and computational methods
to manage, search, and analyze the data.
The theme runs along the axis from data
to discovery. First, the storage, index,
and search of terabytes to petabytes
of big data require advanced databases.
Just imagine, your laptop probably
has several Gigabytes of hard disk.
However just one set of our experiments often
generates one or more terabytes of data,
which is too large to fit in your laptop. Managing
such big data requires advanced database systems.
Analysis of noisy big data requires
the development of many algorithms,
software tools, and web servers. These make
up a big portion of bioinformatics research.
A tradition in bioinformatics since the
early days till today has been to make
most algorithms and software open source. This
has contributed significantly to the broader
life science research, and had helped to advance
bioinformatics itself as well. With these tools,
we can do a lot of data mining to discover
new patterns and phenomena in life science.
Finally, by integration of data and tools, we can
build predictive models of biological systems.
As more and more high-throughput technologies
are used more and more in life science, there
will continue to be numerous new opportunities
for technology innovation in bioinformatics.
To meet this challenge, a new breed of
professional that could collaborate and
communicate with biomedical researchers,
clinicians, quantitative scientists and
bioethicists is needed to translate the
genomic knowledge to improve patient outcomes.
In summary, healthcare analytics, health
informatics or bioinformatics are basically tools
transform raw biological, patient and prescription
data into meaningful and useful information used
to enable more effective strategic, tactical,
operational insights, and decision-making.
Data is now available more digitally as technical
advances have made it easier to collect and
analyze information from multiple sources. The
government, regulatory agency and other public
stakeholders have been opening their vast
stores of healthcare knowledge, including
data from clinical trials and information on
patients covered under public registry programs.
In parallel pharmaceutical companies have been
aggregating years of research and development data
into medical databases, while payors and providers
have digitized their patient records in EHR.
As healthcare becomes a greater portion of
expenses for employers, public, private,
and patients, there is an increasing focus
on analytics to drive efficiency and value.
Therefore, it is important that the best
data analytics and informatics professionals
collaborate on transforming the way data is
gathered, maintained, and analyzed through
technology solutions. Healthcare analyst,
health informaticist and bioinformatician
need to integrate and collaborate with clinicians
and experts who understand the healthcare system
and use data analytics, and leveraging the
strengths of each profession effectively.
Working as a team, informatics and analytics
professionals are bridging the gaps and
introducing action-oriented improvement
opportunities with the intention and
potential of improving healthcare safety,
quality, efficiency, and cost of care.